many of you know I've been talking a lot
lately about YouTube policies and
algorithms and how they affect our show
and other shows there's been a lot of D
monetization YouTube's been bearing
independent political shows like ours
and there's a bigger conversation about
social media and censorship also
happening which really exploded the day
I was on the Joe Rogan program involving
steven crowder and carlos masa and that
debacle as well as recent content and
policy enforcement on twitter and this
has really been relevant for years but
lately it's been snowballing in
particular with channels like ours and
other political channels because there's
a lot of misconceptions about why
YouTube and Facebook and Twitter are
doing what they're doing as well as
exactly what it is that they're doing so
let's talk about how users and content
creators are affected but then talk
about the big picture issues in social
media and how we should be thinking
about them I'll tell you what the
problems are but I'll also tell you what
the problems are not and maybe most
importantly the solutions that we should
be looking at so on platforms like
YouTube and Twitter the more popular you
are as a content creator the more likely
you are to be targeted with censorship
and D monetization if and until you get
big enough to be exempted from some
restrictions because of a special
account status that can be available in
some cases but then social platforms
will sometimes enforce policies
differently when there's a high profile
controversy they'll be accused of
platforming harmful speech or of being
anti free speech they start feeling the
heat from the public from one side or
the other and then they start making
decisions and enforcing policies in ways
we haven't necessarily seen before and
often those enforcement's will happen in
ways that fly directly in the face of
both the letter and the spirit of the
Terms of Service of a platform or their
mission statement about free expression
and dialogue or whatever and sometimes
they'll even end up making up new
policies on the fly right in the middle
of a scandal sometimes I'll happen to
agree or disagree with a specific call
that a
company might make whether it's taking
someone off of a platform or reversing a
ban on someone who I didn't think
actually deserved it but the problem as
I've said before is the inconsistency a
company will claim to stand for certain
values and then they'll fold under
pressure when it's a better PR move to
do the opposite and it creates a
completely dysfunctional ecosystem for
everyone and sometimes the problems are
even more fundamental we upload about
eight videos to YouTube a day and on
some days as many as 75 percent or
demonetized for not being quote brand
safe so we don't make any money from
those videos sometimes it's predictable
based on YouTube the monetization
guidelines but the problem is the effect
that this has on our ability to produce
serious news without concerns about
monetization to be clear I wouldn't and
I haven't changed the content of the
show to stay monetized on YouTube I
cover the stories that are important
YouTube can and does they monetize them
but the david pakman show is a small
business and I need to make projections
and have an understanding of where will
revenue come from so this application of
policy is a distraction from simply
producing the best content we can if
YouTube will allow us to collect revenue
from our videos that's great or if a
large portion of our videos will be d
monetized then we need to deal with it
and figure out how else to fund the show
the real problem is that by all accounts
our content should be monetizable we
don't show graphic violence we don't use
profanity I'm never sitting here using
drugs or harassing people or belittling
people based on their race or gender our
content would be monetized were it not
for advertisers imposing their will on
YouTube and YouTube having little choice
but to go along with it this is not a
left-wing right-wing thing people on the
right like to say it's happening to them
because they're conservative but it's
happening to independent political shows
that are across the political spectrum
including mine it doesn't seem to be
affecting the big corporate media
outlets that have YouTube channels
nearly as much and sadly this is part of
a theme we've been seeing with you too
lately independent political channels on
the left and right the David Pakman show
Kyle kolinsky steven crowder these types
of people we've realized that YouTube is
in general hindering our shows and
deterring people from watching
bolstering legacy corporate media
outlets that have YouTube channels
whether it's CNN NBC News or late-night
talk shows in July of 2018 YouTube
actually made an announcement that they
would start making quote authoritative
news sources more visible on the
platform in a press release YouTube said
today we're announcing steps we're
taking with the Google News initiative
to support the future of news in online
video and product features we've been
working on to improve the news
experience on YouTube we believe quality
journalism requires sustainable revenue
streams and that we have a
responsibility to support innovation in
products and funding for News they go on
to say authoritative miss essential to
viewers especially during fast-moving
breaking news events so we've been
investing in new product features to
prominently surface authoritative videos
when you're watching a YouTube video you
see a list of other suggested videos on
the right side of the page on desktop or
below the video on mobile when you're
finished watching a video before the
next one plays you see a similar set of
suggested videos appear what shows up
here these suggested videos is
controlled by YouTube's recommendation
algorithm a large portion of our traffic
has always come from these suggestions
someone's watching a video about
whatever YouTube suggests they watch
another video by the david pakman show
about a related topic this has been a
really important source of video views
for us and it's a really good way of
allowing people to discover our channel
for the first time our YouTube dashboard
tells us where our video views come from
and we're now getting only about half of
the recommendations that we were getting
about a year ago and the decline started
right after YouTube announced they would
prioritize quote authoritative news
sources so not only is YouTube D
monetizing the views that we do get
they're also causing us to get fewer
views
to begin with which hurts the channel
now this is not some underhanded plot to
destroy the David Pakman show yes
they're changing their algorithm in a
way that hurts us but I understand what
they're trying to do and why they're
trying to do it sadly this is the same
reason that Breitbart and Infowars and
other extremists fake news sites don't
show up in search results when you go to
news.google.com Google and YouTube want
to placate advertisers by preventing
accusations that they are perpetuating
or allowing the monetization of
misinformation fake news hate news and
extremist content but the reality is
that whatever the motivation my channel
similar independent channels which
should not be lumped in with fake news
and hate channels are getting caught up
in it and frankly it could destroy many
of the channels like ours if it
continues and so far it's continuing we
all know the types of channels YouTube
wants to make less visible the Sandy
Hook conspiracy people alt-right
extremism red pill black bill people
misogynists racists homophobes people
targeting others on the basis of sexual
orientation all of the types of channels
that over the years
YouTube has gotten a lot of flack for
platforming YouTube is fighting a
negative image of in part being a garden
of not jobs and hate and extremism
YouTube wants to fix their brand and
maintain their brand I can see why they
want to do that but shows like ours are
getting hurt by the algorithm to the
detriment of speech and ideas to
understand how to interpret and deal
with this and we need to have some
shared starting point something that
many people do which completely fails to
properly frame the conversation about
censorship and the monetization is to
say that YouTube and other social media
companies like Twitter and Facebook are
left-wing they say these platforms are
silencing or disincentivizing speech
that's politically incorrect or speech
that is generally considered offensive
when it comes to race nationality gender
sexual orientation religion many people
are taking this and conclude
that the social media companies have a
left-wing agenda yes
hateful or offensive speech is more
likely to come from someone on the right
when Steven Crowder calls
Carlos masa a gay Mexican lispy queer
and gets his videos demonetised that's
not something you're really gonna hear
from people on the left very often and
it's the kind of speech that's going to
get you in trouble on some of these
social media platforms in that sense
it's possible that right-wingers face
more repercussions than people on the
left I don't know that to be the case
but it's possible but using that to say
that these companies are fundamentally
progressive or left-wing doesn't
actually help us understand these issues
and it's not accurate conservatives have
a conspiracy theory that social media
companies are simply bleeding-heart
political activists waging an
ideological war against the right the
reality is these companies have no as
company's ethical or ideological
philosophies or positions they are
motivated by business interests these
companies by the way as I said to Joe
Rogan are also very right-wing or
libertarian right libertarian in many
ways in terms of the policies they
support and the role that they play
Google is currently in an antitrust
battle with the Department of Justice
Facebook is the subject of a huge
antitrust investigation by the Federal
Trade Commission these companies are
huge tax dodgers they want to
self-regulate
they lobby for deregulation the same as
the air polluters and the big banks and
the gun manufacturers what Google and
Facebook and Twitter do every day in
Washington is in the most literal sense
the opposite of progressivism having an
internal culture that's socially
progressive first and foremost doesn't
mean that as a company they are
progressive in their public role but in
addition to that even what appears to be
left wing and thought internal culture
is often just brand management their
politically correct content policies and
the way they enforce them and what they
say publicly about content policies it's
not virtue signaling it's a signal to
their advertising clients and
they're shareholders and this should be
obvious YouTube and Twitter clearly have
no authentic principled stance on
protecting offensive speech or on
combating offensive speech this was most
recently demonstrated by their
flip-flopping embarrassing flip-flopping
on the Crowder maza situation one side
got mad at YouTube YouTube conceded the
other side got mad at YouTube YouTube
then conceded to them they panicked they
tried to find the right balance between
protecting their image in the eyes of
advertisers and understanding that
that's the source of their revenue but
protecting their image in the eyes of
the public as well who are the people
that need to watch those advertisements
YouTube isn't evil or virtuous Twitter
isn't left-wing or right-wing these are
corporations they exist to generate
revenue and perpetuate themselves so
maybe you're saying well we still have
this problem though that these companies
have a monopoly on social media and
they're silencing offensive speech
they're recklessly D monetizing
political commentators who don't deserve
it and that is what we're faced with a
solution that's often proposed is that
we regulate these companies that we use
the government somehow to enforce free
speech on the platforms which is already
problematic language they want us to
treat these platforms like public
squares establish free speech
protections for all of the users but
these arguments fall flat the First
Amendment protects you from censorship
by the government not by private
entities the government shouldn't be
able to force a company to allow you to
use their software and their networks
this isn't a civil liberties issue
social media companies do and should
have every legal right to maintain and
enforce their own content policies to
prioritize certain content to protect
their brand or for any other reason that
they have or none at all unless they're
doing something like discriminating
against users of a certain race or
religion which violates the law what
government body is going to enforce
so-called free speech on social media is
it going to be Congress whose political
bias changes every few years will it be
the FCC or the FTC as Donald Trump is
thinking of doing who's put
little bias also changes every few years
we know that the current administration
wants based on this executive order that
they're putting together for them to be
the ones who decide based on their
politics who gets to say what and which
platforms get punished that's dangerous
conservatives don't want this type of
government regulation anywhere else they
just want government regulation here
because things haven't been going their
way the free market has demonstrated
that offensive content is bad for
business and they now want special big
government nanny state protections
against what is being caused by free
market capitalism quite frankly or the
version of it that we have I'm being
negative negatively impacted by one of
these companies YouTube is hurting me
financially they're diminishing my
village and my ability to voice my
opinion but that's not making me lose my
objectivity about the rights of private
companies or how impractical it would be
to have the government oversee social
media content the first step in the
correct direction is going to be for us
to stop viewing social media as one
collective thing or entity different
social media platforms serve different
purposes twitter has developed a service
that's very different than Facebook the
mechanics are different the culture is
different the etiquette is different
some platforms allow porn some don't
some platforms allow spamming some don't
some platforms require you use your real
name and others don't all social media
platforms are different because they're
geared to different markets and have
different purposes the average person
using tumblr is different than the
average person using kora for example or
at least they use the two platforms for
very different reasons social media
companies intentionally develop their
platform to have a particular
environment catered to the market they
want to serve in the same way that a
platform designed for professional
networking wouldn't be any good as a
medium for sharing funny memes and
vice-versa a platform designed to serve
a somewhat universal mainstream user
base and attract mainstream advertisers
may not function properly is a platform
for exchanging controversial ideas or
vice-versa
many social media platforms that are
marketed as free speech alternatives to
mainstream platforms some are I like
personally others seem to be cesspools
of hate and sketchiness but the idea of
forcing that content onto privately
owned platforms that don't want it and
may be financially harmed by it doesn't
make sense
YouTube serves a particular purpose it's
an invaluable service to the vast number
of content creators who otherwise
wouldn't have a platform to so lucrative
ly distribute their content it's been a
really great thing for most independent
video creators I've been asking for a
more clear understanding of how the D
monetization works as it pertains to my
content I'm not creating content that's
fringe or extreme or disturbing or gory
or whatever the way that YouTube is
suppressing many independent channels as
if they were doing that is antithetical
to what made YouTube cool and
interesting to begin with but ultimately
it is YouTube's right it's my right to
complain about it it's my right to leave
YouTube or start my own YouTube if
that's what I want to do maybe it is
actually the best business decision for
them maybe it's just more worth it to
YouTube to take a better safe than sorry
approach to the way that they're de
monetizing me and to just push the
corporate media channels and not worry
too much about the collateral damage to
programs like mine in the end I don't
know that I can do that much about it
this is why it's so important for the
audience's of independent political talk
shows like ours to realize that the
show's can only exist unfettered through
direct support from the audience
especially if the YouTube algorithm and
the D monetization stuff gets worse it's
not just a talking point it's not a way
to get people to sign up for david
pakman show membership it's just reality
if we don't have reliable YouTube
revenue and we don't have reliable
financial support from the audience
we may have to figure out something else
maybe I'll have to get a different job
if you're not on YouTube to watch makeup
tutorials or cat videos and what you
want to do is watch content like ours
that's trying to shake things up trying
to deal with serious issues in an adult
way and rubbing some people the wrong
way admittedly then may
we all need to assess our roles as
consumers of shows like this one even
though these shows can be accessed for
free there are cost to the creator's
employees salaries employee health
insurance rent internet electricity
equipment connectivity so many other
things a political commentary show
relying more on direct support from the
audience than on YouTube ad revenue is
actually probably a better paradigm for
everybody involved it means that if you
are a patron of something that you value
and you're educated and entertained by
it instead of you and your clicks
becoming a commodity to YouTube's bottom
line through your cable subscription or
watching ads or whatever else it would
mean content creators would be more free
to do and say what they want
unbeaten to advertisers and that freedom
and integrity is something that's
crucial for shows and put the political
commentary sphere it probably also means
that you might even end up with more
content creators to choose from because
they'd be better funded or you'd have
higher quality content because people
doing this part-time could focus on it
full-time as an example when you pay for
content you're not just getting what you
paid for you're investing in something
you value so that it can sustain and
grow and improve so this is not a
promotion for our patreon page or our
membership program this is something I
personally find it not only fascinating
but of crucial importance from a Media
Studies point of view and it's something
that applies to the entire digital media
industry these are my thoughts but it is
something that is affecting online
political shows like this one and I do
believe that independent political shows
are particularly important to protect
when we see this administration wanting
to come up with new and novel ways to
suppress speech they don't like and to
mandate speech they do like be published
regardless of what a private company
wants to do what we ultimately need is a
big picture meta shift in how we think
about online content how we consume it
and what we are willing to do to sustain
it and guard it from outside influences
and I hope that's what you'll take away
from this today